Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Familiar question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
I wasn't either.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs,
your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world and here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world,
we'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettlebells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear@onnit.com forward slash Tim.
That's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any
supplements,
food products.
I like hemp force,
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash Tim.
Good and talk my 60 leaky munchkins.
This is Tim Ferriss in a very echo ladened wouldn't room on an island and we'll
be hearing more about that in a future episode with Chris Saka.
But in the meantime,
I am so excited to present an episode that was a very,
very physically demanding.
And this conversation you are about to listen to is with none other than Rick
Rubin.
And if you don't recognize that name,
well the bio could seem almost fabricated.
It is so impressive.
So he has been called the most important producer,
that's music producer for the last 20 years by MTV.
And in 2007 he peered on time's 100 most influential people in the world list.
Why would he appear on such a list?
Well,
if you could imagine,
say in the book world that you named every author you could think of off the top
of your hand,
all the name brand folks,
and then found out that one agent and one editor,
we're responsible for all of them.
You'd be dumbfounded.
And that's pretty much the case when you look at the discography of Rick Ruben.
So he was the former co President of Columbia records.
He's cofounder along with Russell Simmons of def jam records and help to
popularize hip hop music by working with the Beastie boys,
ll cool j public enemy,
run DMC for instance.
And I'm not going to give the whole list because it's too long,
but here are just some of the artists that he has worked with.
Red Hot Chili peppers,
Beastie boys,
which I already mentioned,
Johnny Cash slayer,
Jay Z.
And he appeared in the 99 problems video Danzig,
Dixie chicks,
Tom Petty,
and the heartbreakers black sabbath,
slipknot,
Metallica,
ACDC,
Arrowsmith,
Lincoln Park,
Weezer the call Neil diamond,
a Mick Jagger system of a down.
It goes on and on.
And these genres span from say,
Lady Gaga to Zz top to Shakira and everything in between.
Kanya West,
m,
and m,
you name it.
So he's a fascinating guy.
Uh,
very much a zen monk in his temperament.
And I've gotten to know Rick over the last few years and he insisted that we do
the podcast in his sauna,
which is a barrel sauna that makes your head melt.
It is so intense.
So this was a very challenging episode.
I hope you get some laughs out of it.
And uh,
what you will realize very quickly is you have to listen intently to Rick's
answers.
So Rick has it of layers behind layers,
behind layers.
So he'll tell you something and you're like,
wow,
I'm not sure I actually get what that means.
And then months later it'll dawn on you.
Oh my God,
there are so many different depths to that answer.
I didn't pick up on it the first time around.
So,
uh,
you will have to interpret and ponder a lot of what Rick brings up and I hope
you enjoy this.
Uh,
I enjoyed it,
although I nearly had heat stroke.
And without further ado,
here is Rick Ruben.
Well,
will almost without further ado,
folks,
one more or do I forgot to mention?
If you are interested in music,
be sure to check out the drumming episode of the Tim Ferriss Experiment,
which is my TV show.
It's been the number one TV season on iTunes now for some time,
amazingly.
But if you go to itunes.com forward slash Tim Ferriss two r's,
two s's,
you can see a bunch of bonus footage,
all of the episodes including the drumming episode where I am trained by Stewart
Copeland,
the founding drummer of the police,
widely considered one of the top 10 drummers of all time.
His teaching method resembles doc from back to the future.
It is an amazing experience and I only had a few days with a gun against my head
to train to then play to a sold out auditorium as the Drummer for foreigner,
uh,
which was a nervous breakdown inducing to say the least.
So you can check it out.
itunes.com forward slash Tim Ferriss,
two r's and two s's.
And now here is Rick Ruben.
Rick,
welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me.
And this setting is somewhat unique and I've been looking forward to it slash
fearing it ever since.
You first mentioned it,
me,
uh,
where are we right now?
We are sitting in the sauna.
We here sitting in a very hot barrel son and I was told that I was one of the
conditions for having this conversation and it's such an impressive barrel
sauna.
It's indoors that I wanted to get the specs for it when I first saw it.
And you have a heater that has to be what,
four times the size of the off the shelf heater that would go into such a
heated,
it's a much bigger heated and for the size of the room.
And I'm sitting on the floor because I have such little confidence in my ability
to withstand heat compared to you.
But we do have the,
the alternate,
which is the bath just outside of this door and a,
you and I have gone back and forth of course quite a few times with the step of
cycling.
But what is right outside of the store?
A metal tub filled with ice.
It is a metal tub about four feet,
three and a half feet off the ground full of ice.
Uh,
looks like if you were to say what a horse trough times to something like that,
something like that.
It's gotta be maximum low fifties,
I think it's about today.
It's probably about 38 degrees.
Oh my God.
All right.
So we have a,
we have two mics on the floor I'm hoping won't explode or melt down to the age
four and the and the h six and we have a water ice heat.
Nothing could go wrong.
I'm looking forward to it.
So Rick,
I was uh,
I was hoping perhaps we could start with,
uh,
a discussion of your physical transformation and I'd love for you to perhaps
just describe to people,
I mean you're in my mind the sort of the,
the picture of a fitness and a lot of ways now and we've been paddle boarding
before and you summarily what my ass,
every time we go out,
I'm always breast.
There are a lot of things contributing to my,
my lack of competency and fear there.
But,
uh,
where,
where were you and how did you end up undergoing this,
this physical transformation because you've lost how much weight at this point
and how much fat Rosen
I lost at the peak moment ls to between 135,
140 pounds.
And I always thought I was eating a healthy diet.
I was Vegan for 20 something years.
And,
um,
all organic vegan really,
you know,
very strict with what I ate.
And doing that,
I got up to 318 pounds.
Um,
and I,
I read a book by a guy named Stu middlemen who ran a thousand miles in 11 days.
And I remember reading that and just thinking,
wow,
it's like I can barely walk down the block.
And this guy ran a thousand miles in 11 days.
And it just seemed so inspiring.
So I read his book and in the book he talked about a guy named Phil maffetone,
who I'd never heard of before,
and he said it in stews book.
He gets to the part where you said,
well,
I met this doctor Phil maffetone and he changed the way I trained and he changed
the way I ate and he changed all these things and then all of a sudden I was
able to do all these things.
It's like,
okay,
I want to find Phil maffetone.
So,
um,
I,
I found him online.
I sent them an email and he was,
um,
living in Florida and I asked if,
if,
you know,
it could become his patient.
And he said that,
uh,
he had just stopped treating patients and retired from being a doctor.
It's like lots of terrible news.
And,
um,
but the reason he decided to stop being a doctor was he decided to become a
songwriter.
And I said,
oh,
it's interesting.
Um,
I mean,
funny you should mention that.
Like,
I'm involved in songwriting and the music world.
Maybe we can trade and maybe I can help you with your song writing and you can
help me with my health and fitness.
And he liked the idea and we ended up meeting a few months later and then,
um,
met several times and became friends.
And then you eventually ended up moving into my house and lived in my house for
about two years.
And,
um,
I did everything he said and I got much healthier.
My metabolism gut turned on.
Um,
the hours that I was sleeping shifted.
I for most of my life,
I stayed up all night and slept most of the day.
And,
uh,
when I was in college and never took a class before 3:00 PM because I knew I
wouldn't,
I wouldn't go.
And this was at Nyu,
at Nyu,
so I'm used to living in Knight and lifestyle.
Even I remember even in high school,
I've missed,
I missed the first three classes of schools so many times that,
you know,
it was really an issue,
but it was just,
I had learned to be up on,
I've learned to be a late night person and,
um,
and it kind of suited the music life click.
It worked well with my life.
Um,
and one of the first things that feel suggested when we got together was,
um,
I slept with blackout blinds and I usually didn't leave the house until the sun
was setting.
And he said,
from now on,
when you wake up,
I want you to go outside.
Oh,
as soon as you wake up,
open the blinds and go outside nicotive possible and be in the Sun for 20
minutes.
And when he said it,
I remember thinking he,
it'd be the same as him saying,
I want you to jump off this,
this ledge.
You know,
like,
it sounded like the most terrifying based on the way I lived my life.
That just sounded terrible.
Right.
Um,
what time was he recommending that you wake up?
Well,
she,
by the time we started it kept moving down and it,
and it,
um,
it went from three o'clock to probably noon to 11 to nine,
and it just sort of happened naturally.
And he knew that if I immediately went in the sun,
that naturally my body would want to start waking
up earlier and going to sleep earlier.
I,
it was the first time ever that my circadian rhythm was kicking in.
It never was.
I never knew that there was such a thing or knew what that was.
So he,
um,
he got me to connect to that and I did everything he said changed my diet,
started eating some animal protein.
I was,
as I said,
a devout Vegan,
so eggs and fish with the first things that I would eat.
And even then,
I never liked eggs and they never liked fish,
so I ate them more like medicine.
Um,
and slowly I got healthier and healthier and healthier and more and more fit.
But I was still very heavy and I was heavy for a long time.
What age were you when you brought him into your house?
Or how long ago was this?
Yeah,
I'm going to guess.
Okay.
I'm going to guess it was probably
okay.
Late thirties.
And how,
if you don't mind me asking me 10 years ago,
10,
12 years ago,
something like that.
So you,
you were changing your diet.
What were some of the other things that he had you change that he had me do?
Um,
20 minutes of a low heart rate exercise,
aerobic activity every day.
And um,
he had me start wearing a heart rate monitor and my heart rate I would get into,
you know,
from me walking up a flight of stairs would be an aerobic activity.
So I had to really watch what I was doing to stay.
I don't Rebecca activity.
Yeah.
So I had to
work hard to stay in the anaerobic space or the aerobics space.
You mean in the aerobic space below that it's getting hot in here to take off
all your clothes.
My hands,
my hands burning,
holding the bag.
I tried to wrap them in Napkins.
I remember he did,
did mention those might get hot,
but sorry,
I digress.
So to stay within the aerobic threshold you had yes.
Worked very hard.
Yes.
And uh,
again my health changed but I still stayed very heavy.
And after two years of time,
um,
I probably,
I probably lost a little bit of weight,
but not much.
But I was much healthier and much more alive and much better than I was before.
And after that period of time,
Phil said to me,
you know,
anyone else who made the changes you made out of everyone he's ever dealt with,
99% out of 100 people,
you know,
99 out of 100 people would have dropped all their weight for some reason.
There's something else going on with you that's holding onto the weight.
So,
and so I just accepted that that was how it was.
But at least I felt it felt a lot better.
My life was a lot better.
It was lot happier.
Um,
and then I met,
uh,
a mentor of mine whose name is Moe Austin.
He's the guy who ran Warner brothers records for 35 years.
He worked for Frank Sinatra,
real inspiring guy in the music business.
Um,
he suggested I went out to lunch with him one day and he said,
you know,
Rick,
I'm really worried about you.
I know you watch what you eat and I know that you,
you know,
a walk on the beach every day and exercise,
but you're really getting big.
And I'm worried.
So he said,
uh,
I'm going to get the name of a nutritionist and I want you to go to my guy and I
want you to do whatever he says.
And I said,
okay,
fine,
look at.
And I knew it wouldn't work because I knew that my whole life I had a weight
problem my whole life.
I've tried every diet and nothing ever worked.
And um,
but I,
you know,
I would do anything for most.
So I went again openminded but not believing it would work.
Willing to try but not believing it would work.
And I'm the nutritionist put me on a high protein,
low calorie diet and I'd never done a low calorie diet before.
And over
14 months I lost 130 pounds.
135 pounds.
Yeah,
it changed.
That changed everything.
And I,
I will say if I didn't do the work with Phil First,
I don't believe that the Diet would work.
There was sort of a,
a combination of things in order.
It was like the metabolism got turned on.
I started being in tune with circadian rhythm.
Um,
I was stimulating my aerobic system every day.
and was,
I built the base and then with the right diet was able to drop the way quickly.
That's so interesting about that.
And I have a couple of more questions about what the nutritionist prescribed,
but is that in my experience with say,
tens of thousands of readers following various diets,
including this low carb diet,
it makes perfect sense because you were,
you were adding things in,
in the beginning as opposed to having everything prohibited and you're adding
elements in.
And then once you've added those lifestyle components,
uh,
at that point you were able to,
to change the,
uh,
the Diet and then experienced the,
wow,
that is hot.
I was going to say,
even with,
even with Phyllo,
I changed my diet.
It just was,
you know,
like almond butter.
It was something that I was allowed to eat because in Phil's world,
almond butter is healthy.
So I probably
a third of a jar of almond butter every day.
That's my issue with things like almond butter,
no food.
Exactly.
The idea of,
uh,
Phil has a belief and so many people have a belief that calories don't
count.
And I understand that,
but if you eat 10,000 calories a day,
right,
you're probably going to gain weight.
You're not going to lose weight.
So it's like there,
there is a point where calories do make a difference.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
there are there cases where it's,
if it's a question of between 40 505,000 calories,
it's like,
okay,
yes.
Bourbon,
calories,
sugar,
calories and fat calories,
very different.
But if you're eating 10,000 calories of almond butter before he go to bed,
yeah,
which I will do if I have almond butter in my house and then best not to have it
in my house.
So the,
when you lost the 130,
140 pounds over that period of time,
how many of your meals,
how many meals are you eating per day,
and how many of them were whole food versus liquid
to lose the weight?
I was having seven protein shakes a day that were,
um,
high protein peaks.
They were like,
uh,
egg protein.
J Rob Egg protein was one of them.
Uh,
terrorists,
whey,
whey protein was another.
And um,
did you alternate those or combine them?
No,
at first I do to only egg.
Mm.
The,
the way came later and uh,
at first I couldn't tolerate the way,
for some reason that the way made me uncomfortable.
Once I lost a bunch of weight,
I could eat the way I'm so egg was first.
That makes that also makes sense.
I mean,
having any amount of lactose or dairy reintroduced after being vegans are for
such a long period of time.
Yeah.
A lot of people have noticed who say try to reintroduce animal proteins feel
sick,
but it's because they lack the enzymes at that point.
After say 10 years of not consuming meat.
Yup.
To digest it properly.
Uh,
do you want to do an ice round or do you want me to do a nice round?
Cause I feel like I'm getting close.
Yeah.
I'd say why don't,
uh,
why don't you do an ice round and then I'll do a nice round,
cause you're at higher elevation.
I'm sitting on the floor for those people who can't see
woo.
No joke.
Oh God.
Even 200 it's not even 200 it's about 190 holy crap.
195 degrees in here.
All right,
so hopefully we'll be up to two twins.
Oh Good Lord to 20 that's a,
yeah,
that's a well done steak right there.
That's a very well done.
All right.
I will hang out in here and then we'll see out there in a minute.
Okay.
I'm holding both of Mike's now sitting on the floor,
two containers of water and I have a Russian spa hat on.
They make you look somewhat like the Keebler elves and mine has a lion on it and
uh,
I have to only guess the cyrillic says spa line,
which is appropriate because I think of myself as spotlight.
On a related note,
folks,
if I do die of heat stroke in here,
it's been lovely knowing you and I'm going to just press stop now to save my
breath for the ice round.
We'll be back and we're refreshed
after some time.
I think we're getting colder adding ice.
But it was about 44 degrees Fahrenheit.
So Rick,
you had,
uh,
mentioned this,
this gent or doctor or lady from Ucla.
Who was that?
Uh,
the doctor at Ucla who helped me lose the weight.
His name was doctor Heber,
eight,
g.
B.
E.
R.
And he really,
um,
he's of everything.
I tried nothing ever worked until Dr Heber.
And do you still follow the general diet or have you been able to after losing
that weight?
Uh,
modify that?
I've,
I've modified it in that I still,
um,
you've a lot of protein and don't have any grain.
Um,
yeah,
really not no carbs and uh,
keep,
while I probably don't restrict calories as much as I did in the weight loss
phase,
I'm aware of it.
I'm aware of them and don't let them get out of control.
Contract.
You've developed a sensitivity and awareness.
And for a period of time I used an APP,
um,
I think it was called fitness pal,
if I can remember correctly,
where you put in all the food that you eat and it tells you the calories and
just kind of keep a log.
And what was just helpful about it is if you pay attention to calories for let's
say a year,
you then really have a sense of where the calories are hidden and you just have
better habits.
Oh,
absolutely.
Just like if you're trying to get into sick ketosis and we're falling,
something like the Atkins Diet for instance,
you develop a sensitivity to hidden sugars.
Absolutely.
And a sort of net carbohydrate.
So I'd love to,
to shift gears a little bit and ask you about music producing.
Uh,
W we'll,
let's,
let's perhaps take even a step back and ask when,
when people ask you what you do,
how do you answer that question?
I don't know how to answer that question.
You don't know how to answer it though.
So what,
what does a,
let's perhaps start with definitions then.
What does a music producer do for those people?
Not Familiar.
I don't know what,
I don't know what music producers do.
Okay.
Tell you I can tell you what I do.
Let's do that.
Uh,
which is,
I help get the best performance from an artist.
Help,
help them pick their material or develop their material and help set the course
for the direction of what they're doing creatively.
And how did you end up initially becoming involved with that type of work?
Um,
I don't know how you usually do and uh,
I guess can do it in many different ways.
Some people might start as a recording engineer and then graduate to record
producer.
Some people might be successful artists and then transition into being record
producers.
Um,
in my case,
I was just really a fan of music and I come at it from the point of view of
being a fan.
What did you study at Nyu?
I started as a philosophy major and then after two years I switched to film and
television because it's holding back friends.
We film and television and it just seemed like more fun.
Was it more fun?
It was,
uh,
I think it's Natalie Maynard.
The Dixie chicks.
Yeah.
It's sad.
And this is paraphrasing,
but that you let music be discovered,
not manufactured.
And this,
this,
uh,
what does she mean by that?
Or what do you think she means by that?
Well,
we have a whole process to pay.
You know,
it's different for every artist,
but,
um,
we,
we try to go on a journey and let the artists discover who they are and in the
process,
um,
the best art comes from them.
It's like getting to be their true selves and trying to take away all of the,
um,
there's so many things that get in the way of the artistic process.
For example,
any commercial considerations usually get in the way.
If you're thinking about
making music,
it's going to get on the radio.
Chances are you won't be using your,
your own voice to its
most potent,
most singular,
um,
you know,
finding the,
what your personal gift is.
Um,
so that's one of it.
That's one of many things.
Just it's a getting closer to the source and not being distracted by any,
uh,
any nonsense that would get in the way of the art being as good as it can be.
What are other things that get in the way of artists producing their best work?
Concerned about what other people think?
Uh,
competition,
wanting to do better than someone else.
See what are the things self doubt,
um,
ego.
What manifestation of ego?
Um,
s if someone thinks that everything they do is great,
they might not be willing to edit themselves enough or work hard enough at,
um,
you know,
if I can write,
if I could write 10 great songs in five minutes each and those are the best
songs and I'm just going to record them and put them out and those might not be
as good as the ones that you've developed over a longer period of time.
For example,
that might be an egotistical artists who thinks everything I do is just great.
When you have the opposite,
when you have an artist who is doubting themselves,
how do you help them through that?
Um,
or what is a,
what do you recommend?
I have a lot.
I mean,
I just speaking personally,
I have continuous self doubt as a redder.
Yeah.
I think most,
I think most artists do that's more the more typically self doubt is the case.
Okay.
I think if your goal is to be better than you were,
you know,
if you're competing only with yourself,
it's a more realistic,
um,
it's a more realistic place to be.
You know,
if you say,
I'm,
I don't want to write songs unless I could write songs better than the Beatles,
it's,
it's a hard road.
But if you say,
I want to write a better song tomorrow,
then the song I wrote yesterday,
that's a realistic,
that's something that can be done.
And if you write a better song than he wrote yesterday,
every day,
then you continued to get better and better and better.
And it really is small steps and um,
and also trying not to,
um,
trying not to think too much because so much of it is more of a,
the job is,
it's more emotion and heart work than it is head work.
Like the,
the head comes in after to look at what the heart has presented and to organize
it.
But the initial inspiration comes from a different place and it's not the head
and it's not an intellectual activity.
It's a,
it's more of a,
um,
it's more inspiration.
So the key first is to really do whatever activities you can to tune into
inspiration and things like meditating help.
And I'm
diving into art in general.
It doesn't have to be even your modality.
I mean,
going to museums and looking at beautiful art can help you write better songs,
reading great novels,
reading great,
great works of art.
Um,
seeing a great movie could inspire a great song reading poetry.
so let's say being in submerging yourself in great art and
the more you can do to get out of the mode of competition where you're looking
at what other people are doing and wanting to be better than them or be inspired
by them.
So the only,
the only way to use the inspiration of other artists is if you submerge yourself
in the greatest works of all time,
which is a great thing to do.
You know,
like if you listened to the greatest music ever made,
that would be a better,
uh,
a better way to
work through to find your own voice to matter today.
Then listening to what's on the radio now and thinking I want to compete with
this.
Right.
So it's more like a stepping back and looking at,
uh,
a bigger picture than what's going on at the moment.
It's someone as speaking as someone who is not very well versed with music.
I don't feel highly literate when it comes to music.
I enjoy music.
But hanging out with,
with you and Neil Strauss,
certainly I feel like I'm lacking perhaps vocabulary to,
uh,
and a lot of references.
Are there any for people who feel like they're in my shoes,
are there any particular albums that you had you could offer as a,
as a starting point?
Not the end all be all,
but just as a,
as a starting point for appreciating a good worldclass contemporary music?
Meaning not necessarily could be classical music,
but are there any record?
I'm an issue.
I would just start by listening to the greats,
which you can look at.
Like,
um,
if you look at search online for Mojo's top 100 albums of all time or rolling
stone's top 100 albums or,
um,
any trusted sources,
top 100 albums and start listening to what you know,
what,
what are considered the great,
that's a good place to start.
And,
uh,
are,
are there any particular stories that you have that come to mind of,
uh,
experiences outside of the medium of music saying a specific film or a specific
trip or specific book that catalyzed a breakthrough in the work that you did?
Let me think about that for a sec.
Yeah.
I wouldn't say break through,
um,
because it's a more,
it's a more personal thing than that.
So it doesn't come as much from the outside.
But I get inspiration every day,
every day from either what I'm reading or watching a sunset or the,
you know,
the w noticing the amount of birds that fly overhead and what they look like and
they're different shapes and paying attention or hearing the sound of the waves.
Um,
all of those things speak to her.
Looking at the horizon.
Um,
they all speak to me and,
um,
so much of the work we tried to do is to
create something with the natural balance that we see in nature.
That that's sort of the perfect version of,
you know,
if you can make a piece of music that can take your breath away as much as a
beautiful sunset,
you've done well.
So,
um,
you know,
any opportunity to see dolphins swim,
wear to see he knows,
see something beautiful that's not your run of the mill experience or even could
be a beautiful cloud filled sky.
MMM.
Were,
you know,
on a particularly clear night when you can really see lots of stars who's there,
they're all inspiring things and um,
help turn on the muse of recognizing
mmm,
kind of,
uh,
a greater vision of either what's possible or what's beautiful.
Then we know something that you see in a magazine that's,
you know,
advertisement that there to entice you to buy it.
And it was,
can you talk a little bit about the,
when you realized that you were good at working with musicians or music,
when did,
uh,
when did that happen?
And are there any particular,
whether it's instances or artists where you're like,
wow,
I think I might actually have a knack for this?
Well,
I started right from the beginning.
I started having a lot of success in it and it,
um,
I did it.
I really made music as a hobby while I was in college and thought I would have a
real job and then I would make music as my hobby and um,
and I thought it would have a job to support my music habit.
And then the first album I produced was,
um,
by ll cool j.
He was 16 at the time and I think it cost us about $8,000 to record it and sold
900,000 comments.
And that was a good start.
That is a good span.
The second one was Beastie boys,
which I think sold,
I don't know,
nine or 10 million.
And I'm from Manhattan,
like just a lot of records sold a lot right from the beginning.
So it,
um,
it'd be,
I will say it took a long time for me to understand
that
that doesn't always happen.
You know,
unusual series of events.
But after a long time of having lot working with a lot of artists and seeing a
lot of success,
it,
it became clear that,
um,
I could support artists and doing good work and people seem to appreciate it.
What are,
what are the,
some of the ways that,
uh,
what are some of the things
or characteristics that make you perhaps different from other people who work
with musicians?
Yeah.
It's hard to know.
I don't know so well what other people do,
but I,
I,
I don't think we do the same thing.
And I think,
um,
there some producers who
yeah.
Um,
make beats for artists.
And um,
there was a time that I did that early in,
early in my career.
I did that.
I'm still on occasion.
We'll do it if you know,
if it,
if it makes sense with the,
the project that I'm doing.
Um,
I think it's unusual that I get to work in lots of different genres and get to
make heavy metal records and rap records and country records and spiritual
records.
I'll do all different kinds.
I think that's unusual.
And just lucky.
And I think that might come from the fact that I come from it,
from that fan perspective and I like all kinds of music and I get to um,
examine them and,
and,
and the fact that I've been able to work on so many different kinds of music
over such a long period of time gives me a good perspective because when I come
into a new project,
it's not,
it's,
it's rare that I'm going into the studio to work on another of what I was just
working on.
So let's say for example,
I was a heavy metal producer and all I did for the last 30 years,
we've produce heavy metal.
I don't know how fresh those records would be today,
but now if I get to produce a heavy metal record,
like the last one I did I guess would be the last black sabbath album.
He was really fun cause I hadn't made a record like that in a long time.
And it was a brand new experience and it was 13.
13 was the last one.
Yep.
And um,
that was a great experience.
Really Fun.
Never worked with those guys before and we had a great time.
So I'm not sure I ever told you the first time I ever saw the name Rick Rubin
was actually on the inside of a,
an audio cassette.
It was the first heavy metal album I ever bought,
which was raining blood.
Oh,
that's a good one.
And I just remember that's a really good not having is this beef Internet of
course.
And I was just told by my friends,
you have to,
you will love heavy metal,
you should listen to heavy metal.
And I asked what the hardest heavy metal was that could possibly be found and
reign in blood came,
uh,
to the lips of those I asked.
And uh,
and I just remember listening to you.
I think it's angel of death,
the first track on that and going,
oh my God,
what have I gotten myself into?
Yeah.
And just fell in love with that band.
But how did you go from hip hop to say slayer?
It's,
it's a stylistically so different it would seem,
but how did slayer come about?
As I said it right?
Because
it was coming about it with no technical skill.
It's not like I knew about hip hop or I knew about heavy metal.
I was a fan of music and I loved heavy metal and I loved hip hop.
So it was more of that coming at it from this appreciation and as a knowing what
I wanted to hear,
knowing that,
you know,
especially in the case of slayer slayer,
we're an underground metal band who had two albums out on an independent label
and we're kind of considered,
you know,
the heaviest band in the world.
And when we signed them,
there was this terrible fear that slayer now doing their first album for a major
label,
it was going to,
you know,
they were going to sell out,
get watered down.
Yeah.
And which happens all the time.
And then the album that we made,
random blood was much harder and worse than anything that anyone ever heard
before.
And um,
and it really did come from that,
you know,
I liked,
I always liked extreme things and they were extreme and I wanted to maximize it.
I didn't want to water down,
you know,
the,
the idea,
the idea of watering things down for a mainstream audience,
I don't think it applies.
I think people want things that are really passionate and the best version of
ethic they could be in.
Often the best version they could be is not for everybody.
Right?
The best,
the best art divides the audience where you,
you know,
if you put out a record and half the people who hear it,
absolutely love it and half the people who hear it absolutely hate it.
You've done well because it's pushing that,
that boundary.
If everyone thinks well,
that's pretty good,
why bother making it,
you know,
it's sort of,
um,
it doesn't,
it doesn't mean much lost in the slipstream of time.
Almost as soon as it comes out.
I'm going to do around device,
if that's all right.
Absolutely.
All right,
let's do some more ice and we'll be back.
Okay.
We are,
we are back.
And I'd love,
I'd love to talk a little bit about,
say for instance,
ll cool j versus slayer.
Is the way in which you work with those two groups of creatives or in the case
of helical jet,
I know how many people were in involved on his side,
but is,
is there a different approach when giving feedback when trying to cultivate
their booty?
It's,
it's really different with every single artist and it's um,
you spend time with the artist,
you get to know them and if you,
if you listen to people,
if you really listen to what people say,
usually
they,
um,
they tell you everything.
If you really listen and pay attention to what people are saying,
they'll let you know a lot of stuff.
And,
um,
I just really pay attention to what people say.
And through that I can then reflect back,
um,
thoughts that
they've told me about themselves that they don't know about themselves and um,
allow them to unlock those doors too
to get to the places they want to go artistically.
Are there any particular examples of that where a,
or a story that you could share?
Uh,
the first story that comes to mind isn't related to my music work,
but it's related to our friend Neil and I'm just the journey,
the journey that led to his new book that that's about to come out.
Um,
started through him complaining about something going on in his life that,
uh,
he thought was something that he wanted in his life.
I don't think that he knew that he wanted,
was making him unhappy.
And through that conversation he decided to examine that.
So that'd be an example.
Would be the same,
same thing as that.
The threats one that came to mind,
maybe because we both know Neil,
right?
Uh,
yeah,
you seem very obviously philosophical,
philosophically minded,
very calm.
Uh,
and uh,
I should thank you also,
uh,
you and a friend named Chase Jarvis,
or actually,
you know,
if he's a world class photographer or the people that got me into meditation,
I consistently with Tm.
Great.
So thank you for that.
But have you always been very calm and uh,
I mean you seem very unperturbed very unphased by,
by anything that I've observed.
Is that,
is that,
is,
is that an illusion is,
or have you always been that way?
MMM,
I'm very lucky in that I learned to meditate when I was young,
so I started meditating when I was 14 and I meditated.
Um,
okay.
A lot for a long time and through that I think it has really,
um,
okay.
Even,
even though I'm not always calm on the inside,
it has least given me an air of calm and maybe a comparative to other people.
I haven't probably come.
I know sometimes internally I can get disrupted.
What do you do when you get disrupted?
I tried to do something like often,
um,
exercise will make me feel better.
Meditating will make me feel better.
Ice Bath is the greatest of all king of mood elevators.
It's just the magic.
Someone ice back and forth at the end of,
at the end of the fourth or fifth or sixth round of being in an ice tub,
there is nothing in the world that bothers you.
It's true.
It's very true.
Like the world's a great place.
What,
what are the types of things that,
uh,
disruptive?
Are there any particular patterns?
Hmm.
I would say usually,
um,
yeah,
work,
things are political related,
you know,
political type things related to work could really bothered me.
Just,
um,
they don't fit into my,
into my realm of,
uh,
the way I look at life.
So,
so I get surprised by those things.
And just having to manage say the various relationships on the,
uh,
within a a label or something like that.
Yeah,
I would say more like dealing with business people can,
can often like cloud.
You really think that you're the one to do things that way.
Surprising.
How do you,
uh,
how have you designed,
what are some of the ways in which you've designed your life to say,
not have to contend with as much of that as possible?
Well,
I always,
um,
okay,
really try to focus my life around art.
So I consider my job.
Even though there are other parts of my job,
I consider my real job.
The reason I'm here is to
sit with artists,
talk to artists,
help artists be better at what they do.
MMM.
And if I'm not doing it with an artist,
I'm doing it with something else.
It's like my goal is to make things as good as they could be,
either make,
mmm.
Whatever it is.
I mean,
to the point to where I've gone into friend,
visit friends in their office and I rearranged the furniture in there in her
office because that's insane.
You know,
we'd really look better if you,
you know,
if he moved these things this way and you could see the sun coming in through
the window here,
and if you open these blinds and turn this around,
this place would feel much more comfortable.
When you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind?
Okay.
It's not,
it's not such an easy question to answer because I mean,
so many things go into what makes someone successful.
What are some of those things?
Um,
I would start with somebody who's happy.
You know,
I know a great many people who are financially successful and not happy.
So I would rule all of them out to start with.
Wow,
he's not coming Tuesday.
I have to think about that and we'll come back.
We can come back to it.
How do you,
this is a big question,
but I'll,
I'll ask a very self interested question.
Some 37,
of course.
We both spend a lot of time around Neil.
I'm not going to spoil the secret because Neil would have gone to apoplectic
shock.
But,
uh,
the next book I'm looking forward to it.
You just thought of who,
a couple of examples of people who were successful.
Let's do it.
A good example of someone who's successful has done Wildman,
our friend from the beach.
Oh,
who am I still have not met.
Yeah.
Okay.
He's amazing that he's 80 years old.
He's,
um,
23 pull ups on the beach the other day.
He's a,
in the senior Olympics.
He quit,
retired in his fifties because he wanted to spend his days enjoying life and
exercising.
And um,
he's one of the most inspiring,
uplifting,
um,
great,
successful people on so many levels,
on so many levels.
Um,
he'd be,
he'd be probably the first one I think of Laird's another great example of
someone who I would think of as successful.
He's a successful human being.
And this is Luke Laird,
Hamilton,
Laird Hamilton.
Um,
for those people who are not familiar with,
with layered,
uh,
pretty much I'd say
uncontroversially thought of as the King of Big Wave Surfing,
uh,
among,
among other things.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's not uncommon to hear I'm referring to as the greatest athlete on earth.
Um,
he's real,
you know,
so many athletes have so many disciplines.
Think of him as the best athlete,
also a king of,
of steamer and ice pads.
I first started doing the sauna mis when there
anyway,
successful someone who enjoys their life,
um,
is great at what they do,
is curious and continually pushing forward and wanting to be better than they
were yesterday without a,
uh,
okay.
Without beating themselves up about it.
And what are outs?
Uh,
Don don is,
his name,
has come up so many times.
What,
what are some of the things that you've learned or picked up from him and a
adopter yourself?
He,
he's just seems so positive.
And so,
um,
nothing,
it seems like nothing gets to him.
He's,
um,
he couldn't,
he can push through anything that's in his way and all the time with a smile on
his face and a positive outlook and a,
and a curious nature.
You know how,
I don't know how many people that are 80,
that,
uh,
every time you meet them talk,
tell you,
you know,
teach you something about something new they've learned because they're so
curious about a great article or this great book and you have to read this book
and you have to go to see this movie and you have to do this.
And um,
you know,
we just came back from snowboarding and Alaska and you got to go see you was
like,
he was unbelievable.
And just,
it's,
he's got a wildlife
that's inspiring.
I've,
I've in the last,
I'd say three or four years,
particularly after my,
my health scare last year with Lyme disease and everything that came of that
tried to surround myself,
not just with the extremely young athletes and performers,
but,
uh,
for instance,
this Polish gentleman and his wife,
both of whom are world record holders and Olympic weightlifting.
But what's,
what's so fascinating is how relatively injury free and mobile they still are
and their in their,
I'd say early sixties at this point.
And I've tried to really tried to spend more time in the last few years modeling
what those people do.
Uh,
do you have a book or books that you've gifted often to other people?
Um,
there,
there are many.
Um,
first one that comes to mind is the Dao de Jing,
Steven Mitchell,
translation of the Dao de Jing.
That's um,
what's great about it is it's 81 short
pieces that could be,
could look at them as poems that if you were to read the book today,
you would get one thing from it.
And if you pick it up in two years and read it again,
it would mean something entirely different.
And um,
an always on the money,
you know,
always what you need to read at that period of time.
So it's a,
it's a magic book in that way that it,
uh,
it always fits.
I actually took,
if,
God,
this is bringing back a memory,
I took an entire class on the Tao Te Ching at Princeton when I was an Undergrad
and East Asian Studies.
And it seems on some level that that book does what you do for musicians,
meaning it's a sort of reflects back truths that they were not aware of
themselves or they could not verbalize themselves.
Any other books come to mind?
Another one that's really nice,
his book about meditation called wherever you go.
There you are,
which is by a Jon Kabat Zinn.
And it's a great,
it's a great book if you've never meditated and if you've been meditating for 50
years,
if you read,
if you read this book,
either way you'll be,
will care more about meditation,
become a better meditator.
And,
um,
just give insight into why we do it and what the benefits are.
Do you have any favorite,
any favorite movies or documentaries
and watch lots of documentaries?
Let me think of what's
okay.
What's a favorite?
Just watched one the other night that was spectacular.
New,
um,
uh,
nick cave,
the English,
well I guess he's Australian,
but lives in England.
Um,
musician has a,
there's a new documentary that's an unusual documentary cause it's Hart
documentary in part,
I guess not yet to see it,
but it's called 20,000 days on earth.
20,000 days on earth.
Yeah.
So that was the last one that just really like,
wow.
How great is that?
Okay.
Are there any points?
Uh,
okay.
Have you had any points of,
of overwhelm in your length in Europe?
Uh,
and your length in your,
that's an odd question.
I think the heat's getting to my head.
In your,
uh,
in your career.
Getting Heat's getting to me to switch because my hand is burning.
Okay.
Uh,
do you experience overwhelm or have you
yes,
I definitely experience overwhelm.
Yeah.
Oh,
too much going on at one at one time or,
um,
often it's,
it's a self imposed
Aye.
All right.
Make it a point to always be there as best as I can be for the artists that I
work with and sometimes,
uh,
their needs can overtake my own needs and then I feel overwhelmed because I want
to be there for them and then I feel like go,
I'm not taking care of myself.
So finding that balance,
what do you,
what do you do in those situations when you,
when you come to that realization?
When I realize it,
I'll usually talk to the artist about it and,
and um,
yeah.
And explained the situation,
seem to look for,
I would say any situation that feels uh,
okay.
Sticky.
Usually through talking about it with the person that it feels sticky with,
almost always it,
uh,
it uses very quickly and usually brings you closer together.
And do you,
how do you explain the situation,
the situation and the way that you just described it to me?
Or it's what,
what is the actual,
it just depends on the
case,
but it,
but I might say,
you know,
I feel really overwhelmed now.
This is what's going on with me.
Um,
can we talk about this later?
Or if it,
you know,
can we address this?
Is that okay?
Or usually talk about it.
Yeah.
Hey,
feeling.
It's getting hot.
Uh,
you tell me.
I'll let,
I'll let you call the call the,
the rotation of the guards when we go to ice.
But I am,
I'm very curious.
I remember,
uh,
seeing your myself.
Uh,
I think this is a fine idea.
I will say I will absolve myself of responsibility for hot objects.
But,
uh,
the,
your cameo in a 99 problems.
Yes.
How did that come about?
Oh,
I had produced a song for Jay and then when it was time to make the video,
um,
a friend of mine,
Mark Romantic was a great video maker,
made the video and um,
I think it was Mark's idea.
She said,
why don't we get Rick in the video and jade greed?
And then they called and asked if I would come.
And I love Jay's really great guy and I thought it would be fun.
Uh,
what,
uh,
what are you proudest of as it relates to that track?
Yeah.
Um,
if it comes to mind,
I know you've worked with a lot of tracks,
just the fact that Jay is one of the most,
you know,
important artists in the world and that's one of his most popular songs.
And then we got to do together.
It was really great.
How were you,
how did you become involved with that song or were you involved with the entire
album?
Um,
I was involved with that song.
We went into the studio together.
He,
it was his last,
it was going to be his last album,
the black album,
his retirement album.
And he asked his 10 favorite producers to each do one song.
And we went into the studio.
That was the first time we worked together and we,
um,
you spend a weekend,
the studio trying different things and then eventually came upon this track and,
uh,
it may experimentation and he loved it.
Men,
the words came to him sort of magically.
He sat in the back of the room listening to the track over and over and over
again.
And after about a half hour jumped up and set up,
got it.
And to the other room and did the vocals.
I'm not writing anything down.
I heard this about him before where,
uh,
at some point I heard a story that heat,
he wrote basically jibberish down on a piece of paper because someone trying to
supervise them earlier in his career was so worried that he wasn't taking the
recording session seriously.
But in fact,
he didn't write anything down at all.
It was just to put them at ease and then freestyle the entire thing.
Is that generally how I operate?
That's how he does.
That's mind boggling.
He's super talented and it was just a great,
great person,
really one of my favorite people.
What do you like about him?
Everything.
He's a humble.
He's honest.
He's,
um,
he's in deep soul.
You know,
he looks at things,
deeply,
understands them,
deeply
caring and um,
it's just,
uh,
you know,
first great person.
I think I'm going to get in the ass.
All right.
I'll do it to the ice.
I'll hit pause.
Wow.
Is Right.
Raises,
right.
It does add up.
That was a particularly Chile ice bath.
It's now lower than the minimum measurement,
which is 40 degrees.
So I feel like how all my skin below my neck is just contracted by 30%.
It's a good feeling.
And you had mentioned this briefly when we were coming in,
but who is,
who is the person who introduced you to using a sun?
You've got the first sauna that I was ever in was,
uh,
a local friend of ours,
Chris Chelios,
who's a hockey player and he was the hit the longest hockey professional hockey
career of,
of anyone ever.
He continued playing professionally until he was 48 years old.
And um,
all of the people on the other teams that he was facing at the time were in
their twenties.
So he's really an unbelievable athlete and he,
mmm.
Has done sauna every day of his life for the last,
you know,
since he's been playing.
And he could,
he believes the reason he had the longevity in the sport and the reason he never
got sick and was able to never miss a game and to play for such a long career
was all due to the sauna every day.
And he used a hot sauna.
He was not alternating between hot and cold.
He did hot and cold,
but he wouldn't necessarily always use an ice bath.
He would do cold showers if not.
Um,
but he would do 15 or 20 minutes in the sauna,
cold shower or 15 or 20 minutes in the sauna round and round.
And to how were you introduced to the ice baths?
Uh,
ice baths came from,
um,
joke,
human Noah,
who's,
um,
my girlfriend's nephew and he,
he bought an ice tub for layered because he's Laird started doing the sauna
after,
after Chris started the sauna.
Uh,
we are a group.
We would do it on the beach.
Chris has a sauna on the beach who do the sauna and even in the wintertime and
then jump into the ocean.
And that was how he did the hot and the cold.
And your QM suggested we started using the ice tub.
MMM.
And then we started doing that and that was,
took it to a whole new level,
done some very unusual training.
That sounds terrifying to me.
Underwater.
Right.
And our,
do you continue to do underwater training with
weights?
Yeah,
that's something that we do with lyric.
We'll do like a 50 pound dumbbells,
14 feet underwater.
And um,
it's,
it's an interesting experience.
A lot like getting into the ice bath,
like if you're not used to getting into an ice bath,
most people,
if you say get into a tub of ice,
they,
uh,
react negatively panic,
they panic.
And when you're underwater holding weights,
your brain goes crazy and it relates to,
oh,
it's like,
wait,
underwater,
you die.
That's like submit shoes.
So we do all of these different exercise weights underwater and it's really
interesting.
Do you,
what do you Saunders,
keep in mind folks do this,
don't do this without supervision.
Talk to your doctor.
But the,
uh,
what,
what is the technique look like?
Or example,
it started,
um,
Laird has a pool that you can start in the shallow end and walk down to the deep
end and then up the center of the pool,
there's a staircase it underwater.
So it started with holding heavyweights,
walking from the shallow end into the deep end.
And obviously there's a point we have to take a big breath and hold it.
And then you walked down into the deep end and then you turn around and you walk
up the stairs and make it before you run out of breath.
And each time you do it,
you would make wider and wider circles and get used to being under longer and
longer.
And then we started adding,
once we were completely submerged,
start adding maybe curls or shoulder presses and doing those underwater.
And then one day after we'd been doing this for about a year,
Laird came into the,
uh,
the gym the next day and he said,
I had a dream last night that if we use lighter weight,
they'll be heavy enough to keep us down,
but late enough where we could get up,
where we could jump up to the top in the,
in the deep end,
in the deep end.
So He'd be down in the deep end.
So now instead of doing one rep and recovering,
which was all we could do before even you can do one round basically,
and then be at the shallow Indian recover,
we started doing these exercises of jumping.
So we'd start with maybe 15 pound dumbbells and you would hold two 15 pound
dumbbells,
jumped into the deep end,
sink to the bottom,
um,
and jumped as hard as he can,
throw your arms over your head and then kind of do one stroke,
pulling your arms down to your sides while holding the dumbbells.
And it was just enough to get your head out and you gasp for breath and then
you'd sink.
And we would do that over and over and over again.
And you know,
at first maybe the goal would be to try to get 10 in a row and it would be
really a big deal and we can do 10 in a row.
And then,
you know,
over time we worked up to being able to do a hundred in a row and then doing it
with heavier weights.
And then since then let's come up with maybe,
I don't know,
50 different exercises that we do with weights underwater,
either underwater or in water.
And while he drives up some really fascinating,
not only exercises but devices that those people haven't seen the foil board,
is that what it is with the toilet boards?
Amazing.
The foil board.
Some people can Google full end up paddling really.
You know,
he invented stand up paddling.
He invented towing,
surfing.
Um,
he's an amazing,
he's got an amazing,
um,
analytical mind.
Do you think,
did he develop that in any particular way?
The mind,
the analytical mind?
I think he's,
um,
I think he's very mechanical to start with.
Think starts with that.
And I'm very curious and very hardworking and he's willing to try things and,
and fail at things to be able to get to,
you know,
to be able to do something.
So he,
you know,
the first day I went to his gym,
um,
I could do one pushup.
And really it was through his,
uh,
his belief in his inspiration that I was able to learn all the different things
that I was able to learn with him.
And I remember he showed me one exercise and I couldn't do it at all.
And I said,
I can't do that.
And he said,
no,
don't say you can't do it.
Say you haven't done it yet.
And then he'd say,
okay,
now let's divide it into three pieces.
Do the first,
third of the exercise.
And I could do the first,
third and I'll do the last third of the exercise.
And I could do that and then do the middle third by itself.
And I can do that.
And he's like,
you know,
but the first two pieces together and I could do that and then put the second
and third piece together.
And I could do that.
And then eventually I could do the whole exercise.
But at first it seemed impossible,
but he walked me through it.
And I'm broken down for you.
Yeah.
It just taught me how to see past the,
um,
the limitations that are put on myself.
What was the exercise?
Do you recall what that was?
That might have been a,
uh,
well,
that could jump through,
like who,
it'd be like a,
like a burpee with weights.
We would
like you do
a shoulder press and then you put the weights down on the ground and then hold
them,
hold the dumbbells,
jumped back into a pushup position,
then jump up and slide your legs forward through.
Right,
right.
And then jump up into a squat position and then lift up.
And that would be one,
one round.
That's an intense movement.
What are some of the,
the physical experiments that you're doing these days,
um,
or training protocols that you're experimenting with and there's always so many.
I have to think of what's,
what's new and
I've been doing hyperbaric oxygen
and I really liked that.
That's an a chamber.
Yeah,
I do.
Uh,
the Wim Hof breathing technique I just started doing,
there's a Wim Hoff 10 week course you could check online.
W.
I.
M H.
O.
F to start it.
He's a fascinating guy.
Yeah.
He's really into ice saying I've never seen anyone more tolerant advice.
I think he has a world record for sitting in a box of Bisquick,
a cube of ice and I think the new climb Mount Everest just didn't swim trunks.
He has some incredible,
uh,
thermo regulatory capabilities thing is very impressive.
You ran a marathon in the um,
yeah.
In the desert with no water.
That was another one.
Yeah.
Just the two extremes of the heat or the cold.
The guy's a monster.
Yeah.
I really want to get him on the podcast at some point.
It'd be a good one.
Let's see,
what else?
Those are the ones that come to mind at the moment.
What,
uh,
how do you just as Laird did for you when you are working with an artist who
believes they can't do something or it's just hitting that wall,
what are some of the ways that you help them get past that?
Um,
usually I'll give them,
um,
the Comark like a small doable task.
And give you an example.
There's an artist that was working on recently who was,
who hadn't made the album in a long time and was struggling with struggling with
finishing anything and um,
and just had this like,
it was a version of a writer's block,
but it was,
uh,
um,
I don't know,
hard to explain what it was,
but I would give him very doable homework assignments that almost seemed like a
joke.
You know,
like tonight I want you to write one word,
you know,
one word in this song that needs five lines that you can't finish it.
I just want one word that you like,
but tomorrow,
do you think you'd come up with one word?
And usually it'd like,
yeah,
I think I can do one word and then just very quickly by chip,
by breaking it down into pieces like I learned from layered and chipping away.
MMM.
One step at a time.
You can,
you can really get through anything.
Yeah.
It's a beach.
We had a um,
okay.
We had a zip line ziplining um,
you know,
the,
the beam that you balance on Oh,
a slack line,
slack line.
And um,
Laird was pretty good at it in the beginning but had never done it before and he
would work for hours.
He would just be there hour after hour after are falling off and getting back
on,
falling off and getting back on.
And then of all of the group of people,
he was by far the first one who was able to do it.
And it wasn't because you just naturally was gifted at it.
He's,
he knows that anything he sets his mind to learn to do if he focuses and just
continues to,
you know,
not mind falling off and not thinking he's supposed to be good out of the box.
Learning to be able to do it and that's how you learn things.
So it's,
I also will say that
after having a weight problem that I had for so long and then finally finding
the solution and making the change.
Okay.
It really makes me believe that anything's possible.
You know,
we can learn,
we can train ourselves to do absolutely anything.
It's really just getting the right information,
forget,
get the right information,
we can learn,
do anything,
whatever it is.
Now,
it doesn't mean we can necessarily,
um,
be the best in the world at something,
but we can be our best at that thing,
right.
The best version of ourselves and do things that never dreamed of as possible
possible for us.
What,
uh,
what advice would you give,
and I'll ask this for a couple of different ages,
but,
uh,
I'll start with,
your 20 year old self.
What advice would you give your 20 year old self if any?
Try to have more fun.
Why do you think you weren't having as much fun as you could have at that point?
I think I was more driven and,
um,
yeah,
I want to say almost like I felt like I had something to prove.
I don't know if I did it have something to prove,
but it felt like
I felt like,
um,
doing the work was the most important thing in the world as opposed to
doing the work and enjoying the process and,
you know,
feeling what it was,
being able to step back and see what it was,
you know,
not just be so deeply into it.
MMM.
Yeah.
I feel like I missed a lot of years of my life because I was just in dark room
working on music,
you know,
seven days a week for probably 20 years.
My,
how I ever called it makes me think of a story from a Neil Gaiman,
the writer when he,
I think it was with the success of Sandman,
and he was in a huge line of readers who wanted signatures and fans.
We wanted to tell him stories and Stephen King pulled him aside and just said,
enjoy it.
And he didn't,
he didn't.
Uh,
he was too caught up in the,
in the flow.
Uh,
what about your 30 year old self?
What advice would you give to your 30 year old self?
I guess I would probably tell myself something that I still might apply to me
today.
Um,
I wouldn't have known it at all of it.
I know it now and just still,
it's not second nature,
but,
um,
two
be kinder to myself.
I beat myself up a lot and um,
because they expect a lot from myself.
I'll be hard on myself and I don't know what I'm doing.
Anyone any good by doing that.
I said I need to give myself as well.
When do you tend to beat yourself up?
I,
I've,
I've made somewhat of a sport of it.
It would seem,
yeah,
it can happen any time I can come up with anything that I could be doing
to further something
and
didn't already think of it and didn't already do it,
I might beat myself up about why,
you know,
why if I had not done that,
something I struggle with that I'd love to get your 2 cents on and uh,
is related to this,
which is on one hand I don't want to beat myself up.
On the other hand,
I feel like the perfectionism that I have has enabled me to do it,
achieve whatever modicum of success I've been able to achieve.
And I,
I've heard stories,
and you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but about for instance,
a Zz top and La for Toyota and uh,
you know how they worked on it with you from,
I guess I want to say what 2008 to 2012,
something like that.
But how they realized the value of a,
you wanting the art to be as perfect as it could be for the best that it could
be and taking whatever time and pains and necessary to make that possible.
Uh,
so I'd love to hear your thoughts on that because it's something that I
continually struggle with.
I want to be easier on myself,
but I,
I worry that if I do that I will lose whatever magic.
If there is such a thing that enables me to,
to do what I do.
I think that ultimately the,
I think that's a myth and I think that um,
your take on things is specific to you and it's not because of your,
you've,
it's almost like you've won the war and to accept the fact that you've won the
war you have broken through to now you have an audience.
People are open to hear,
hear what you are interested in,
what you learn at,
what you're interested in learning about and what you want to share.
And
MMM,
you can,
you can do that without killing yourself.
And that killing yourself won't be of service either to you or to your audience.
All right,
let's uh,
let's,
uh,
this,
this has been great.
I need ice as well.
Let's,
let's call a close to this.
Is there any last parting advice or comment that you'd like to make before we
sign off?
I think it's too,
it's too hot for me to know what's even,
I don't know what's happening,
what's up or down,
very confused at the moment,
but I know that this ice bath is going to change everything.
All right,
well on the,
on that note,
uh,
thanks so much Rick.
Thank you.
We will both get some ice.
I'll let you get out first.
The Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you'll find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettlebells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim.
That's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any
supplements,
food products.
I like hemp force,
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website and APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward,
and many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers,
as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Okay.